es una de las jugadoras de baloncesto
más reconocidas ahora se enfrenta a una
posible condena de hasta diez años de
cárcel brindé gryner lleva casi tres
meses bajo custodia rusa por cargos de
contrabando de drogas las autoridades
han prorrogado su detención preventiva
hasta el 18 de junio
hoy al término de las actuaciones de
investigación se ha prorrogado la
restricción cautelar en forma de
detención durante un mes lo que
significa que podemos esperar que la
acusación final se presente pronto y el
caso se envía al tribunal
este es el tipo de canchas a las que las
7 veces all-star de la doble uve nba
está acostumbrada pero todo esto se
detuvo el 17 de febrero cuando la
jugadora del phoenix mercury fue
arrestada en un aeropuerto a las afueras
de moscú las autoridades rusas alegan
que introdujo ilegalmente en el país
cartuchos de bateo que contenían aceite
de hachís después de meses sin ningún
progreso para lograr su liberación el
gobierno de eeuu dice ahora que ryanair
fue detenido injustamente lo que indica
la intención de washington de tomar
medidas más agresivas para negociar su
libertad la jugada ha generado
expectativas ante un posible canje de
prisioneros con rusia la agencia de
noticias estatal rusa tas dice que moscú
tiene en mente intercambiar a granger
con víctor wood un conocido traficante
de armas ruso encarcelado en eeuu
conocido como el 'mercader de la muerte'
donde está cumpliendo una condena de 25
años por intento de contrabando de armas
a los rebeldes en colombia washington y
moscú han realizado recientemente
intercambios de prisioneros konstantín
iarochenko un piloto ruso que estaba en
la cárcel por cargos de contrabando de
drogas en los estados unidos o
intercambiado por el exmarino 3b ruiz
que estuvo en prisión en rusia acusado
el mes pasado